bâle un
bonjour casimir pas bonjour france soir
ohlala tu m'as l'air bien fatigué non
non je pense à ça alors est dû pour sa
cour mais à rien c'est pas trop
fatiguant quant au contraire c'est très
difficile
bon je te laisse mais ne te fatigue pas
trop j'ai c'est un
bon jour je les salue françois qu'est ce
qui arrive à tenir je ne sais pas très
bien et cela fait un long moment qu'il
est là comme ça ils essaient de ne
penser à rien c'est ce qu'il me dise il
veut oublier
oublié mais quoi je ne suis pas j'ai cru
comprendre qu'il ne se sentait pas assez
inutile tu sais qu'il faudrait lui faire
faire quelque chose et coutumes une idée
il faut que j'aille un rendez vous je
comptais te demander de me garder mais
valent au jeu pourrait le lui ai demandé
ali rami c'est une excellente idée du
jeu train un coup d'oeil de temps en
temps et en fait partie casimir est
si on côtoie
n'excédera casimir nerfs je voulais te
demander de me rendre service un vrai
service important très important mais
françois jacques bordé service on ne
m'en demande jamais je trouve que tu
exagères casimir tu fais beaucoup de
choses utiles dolly nos enfants en tout
cas aujourd'hui je voudrais que tu
t'occupes de mai balocchi d'accord je
les garde boue joli vent
si tu peux en vendre et ou deux ce sera
formidable bien je vais inventer une
idée géniale et je les vendrais tout ça
tranchante casimir je préfère que d'une
agente aucune idée géniale
si durant un ou deux ce sera déjà très
bien bon je vois monsieur n'a pas
confiance en moi monsieur se méfie très
bien gens retournent penser mais
quasiment france mais n'a rien dit
désagréable enfin et a simplement
demandé de vendre ses ballons comme il
le fait lui-même
bon alors c'est d'accord
fin des débats l'enchère et vos bons
ballons wallon par ici les ballots
qu'est ce que c'est non ça c'est pas du
tout le style de l'île aux enfants
qu'est ce qui n'est pas le style de
l'île aux enfants parfois de curieux
comme ça à la cantonade alou ah bon bon
bah excuse moi je me suis trompé
sûrement
quel dommage alors qu'est ce que je
pourrais bien faire pour arriver avant
dans ces ballons qu'est ce qui t'arrive
casimir tu parle tout seul maintenant
non oui enfin je disais que j'aimerais
bien vendre un ballon et casimir est un
peu de patience ça fait deux minutes que
tu installes et tu sais avec tous les
enfants qu'il ya dans l'île tu n'as pas
de souci à ce faire tu vendras beaucoup
de ballons tu crois certainement
mais qu'est ce que je pourrais bien
faire pour vendre ses ballons ils sont
pourtant jolie
julie et skiant que j'ai six mois
j'étais un enfant et bien j'achèterai
beaucoup palau oui seulement c'est toi
qui les vend ben oui il faudrait
vraiment que je trouve une méthode
génial écoute casimir pour te remonter
le moral et pour tous porté chance c'est
moi qui vais l acheter ton prof j'évalue
merci julie a alors lequel veux tu
regardes le bleu le jaune le rouge le
vert les jaunes à ça arrive à faire bien
sûr mon casque à
combien je te dois de francs
c'est pas cher un os non pas du tout
pour un aussi joli ballon bon je
retourne à mon casque bon courage merci
julie
il faut que je trouve une idée
formidable
avec ma malle magique j'ai une solution
je vais trouver un carton et un stylo
et je vais écrire une pancarte
voilà sur l'île aux enfants
vente de ballons unique au monde
occasion à ne pas manquer voilà
parfait
papa papa montrent pas mon papa m'en
tape apparemment pas remis et pias à les
emballer pour casimir bon lequel choisir
le rouge ça se verra mieux voilà
voilà vente unique au monde très bien
dans mon papa tam tam tam tam tam papa
maman papa me parle pas casimir ouais ça
va oui ça va je monte la garde devant
mes balles au
tamis papa maman papa vous
apporte enfin casimir ouais tu cherche
quelqu'un oui j'attends un client à bon
droit
j'allais oublier le principal mon feutre
pour faire les dessins en quel désordre
là dedans ah voilà
voilà
mais enfin casimir est un peu auprès de
thé ballon tu tapes semble tout le temps
tu n'entendras jamais tu as raison j'y
vais
pas
bien comment sont les dessins
voilà c'était vraiment très beau c'est
bah oui ce sont vraiment des ballons
munich au monde casimir qu'est-ce que ça
ça va tu tiens le coup oui ça va très
bien oui par gare voici un client mais
c'est monsieur dix neuf vous notre chers
amis bonjour jambon kazimi bonjour
mathieu dsna bienvenue de honey de moi
mon cher ami je suis très pressé voulait
pas vu françois mais il était un rendez
vous mais il m'a il ne va pas tarder à
revenir nous pouvons lui faire une
commission si vous voulez c'est à dire
que c'est bien ici qu'il ya aujourd'hui
une vente exceptionnelle de ballon
unique au monde une occasion à ne pas
manquer c'est pas casimir tient au
courant oui enfin julich monsieur du
snav venez c'est par la simplicité d'une
vente oui ou non et bien c'est à dire
oui il y avait une bande malheureusement
j'ai presque tout vendu il me reste plus
que 11 11 13 en béton ça casimir je suis
venu tout exprès enfin montre deux mois
quand même les voici
blandine n'est ce pas haut mais c'est
mon portrait et oui vous savez ce sont
mes derniers et j'y tiens vraiment
beaucoup mais si vous voulez pour vous
je veux bien vous les laisser à 10
francs
ce blé ou transcendantale extraordinaire
mais j'achète alors 10 francs pièce mais
n'en parler à personne on nous voulons
une vie propre pièce ça fait eu
différentes en 45 ans maxime bois sont
profondes 10 80 90 ce sont 110 contrats
mais sans dire oui ça me semble d'accord
alors voilà trente secondes
69 coups
et puis attendus sont dix ans voilà
merci à monsieur cent dix ans déjà nous
vivons le pourboire bon merci beaucoup
qui saignait mais voilà attendez vous
partez son compagnon à oui c'est vrai
merci répond que ces convois pour moi ma
très chère amy je vous laisse je vais
exploser une ce petit chef-d'oeuvre
grand salon doit avoir reçu dix neuf je
lis ça y est j'ai tout vendu
bravo casimir voilà l'argent ça fait ça
en france 111 francs pour tous ballon
mais tu les as vendu beaucoup plus cher
que françois non enfin je ne pourrai pas
les vendre au prix normal à monsieur du
snav pourquoi pourquoi j'avais dessiné
son portrait dessus si je leur ai vendu
son portrait à 1 franc pièce il aura été
furieux et vexée d'avoir son portrait
pour un prix aussi bas
casimir
[Musique]
je vais jamais y arriver mais comment je
vais faire c'est pas possible
oh là là
au bon suivi tellement fatigué
fatigué fatigué qu'est ce qui lui arrive
au musée puis saisi mais qu'est ce que
çà et là c'est moi c'est françois on
reconnaît jean-françois ou que sais je
n'en peux plus je suis épuisée que julie
z avance oui je suis mal et c'est un tel
travail je n'ai jamais y arriver et
didot si tu es fatigué avant d'avoir
commencé c'est plutôt de la paresse as
tu crois bonjour susurré
regardes tu vois je dois
je dois prendre ce joyau le porter aux
curieuses provenir prendre celui là le
dr kirk est revenue mais si c'est pour
le quatrième trio c'est après après moi
prendre la brosse et le chiffon voici
venir houston et la haye et acheter
n'est guère poussés reporter la brosse
et 200 élèves de prendre le sourire de
supporter le sont aux stands et je n'y
arriverai jamais mais au fait qu'est
zémire c'est pas difficile pourtant si
c'est j'ai compté le nombre d'allers et
venues entre les stands et le kiosque
moyens sont faits pendant les treize
presse ça porte malheur nominaux sont
très superstitieux mais tu pourrais
faire le même travail ont simplement
trois voyages 3,3 voyage pas un de plus
impossible c'est pas beau c'est
impossible il faut être un génie pour
faire même si en ce moment je suis pas
génial a inventé on y va on va leur
garde attention du ponceau tu prends les
quatre objets jeu 3 il emporte revenir
jusqu'au stand du centre carter j'ai 2
et quatre mois durant la broche faut tu
l'aimés en dessous pour houston qui
profiteront du bros plastique un petit
coup de brosse turenne scifo dessous du
futur pour nos stands
en stands et bah tu vois tu vois trois
voyages crois pas une plaie c'est
parfait tu vois c'est sépare compliqué
et après tu seras pas trop fatigué on on
annoncerait pas fatigués surtout que tu
as fait tout mon travail
merci françois au revoir
[Musique]